[Music]
today we're going to say we're going to
be doing the food you work out some of
the workouts that I have done to get
ready for my guest campaign which I hope
you guys love because I'm so excited but
Kristin and Jenna are both guest models
themselves and we're all going to be
doing this together and show you the
moves right now first we're gonna do
mountain climbers that's where you get
into a plank position and kind of bring
your right foot up and then interchange
with your left leg next we're going to
do bridge lift that's where you lie flat
on your back put your feet flat on the
ground give them a bend and lift your
butt up so every time you lift your butt
up you're giving it a tight squeeze but
as you're doing that you're gonna put
your right foot over your left knee
after that we're going to do leg raises
that's where you get on your hands and
knees bring your right leg up to the sky
bring it across your other leg back up
and down keep doing that for 30 seconds
and then switch legs and then we're
going straight into forward lunges
that's where you bring your right foot
board lunge forward make sure your knee
is not going over your toe go back up
pushing off your heel and straight back
into position repeat until your leg
tires out thirty Seconds switch legs
last but not least sumo Jeff squats
that's where your feet are going to be a
little bit more than shoulder width
apart your toes pointed outwards and
you're going to go down into a squat
position making sure your knees don't go
over your toes
you're gonna spring up into the air lay
me back into your squat position keep
going for 30 seconds that really gets
the heart rate up so those are our moves
and we're gonna go right into it just so
you guys know we're not soft and we're
going all the way through no breaks in
between each move but luckily we're
doing poor around and I'll give you 30
second break and between each round so
let's get straight into it hey are you
ready you ready okay let's do it
[Music]
[Music]
all right right leg up and so ease look
loose I'm slowly gonna start talking
less and less there this video
guys fill it in the butt
[Music]
video
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
- it
[Music]
[Music]
look hot in the beginning well we gonna
go it's real are they like let me
motivate you wait you guys motivate me
first workout language automatically
spring
[Music]
oh my god there's a workout oh man
Kieran talking ha ha that is an amazing
workout I was dying if you couldn't tell
I'm gonna get an interview though real
quick from the guest models so how did
you feel sir all the workout I almost
died dennah now you got one we got so we
worked our booties up and out and
plumping nice yeah and I hope you guys
did the same and tune into the next
video because we're giving you workouts
so make sure you guys comment below
subscribe what you like best keep it
positive so we can keep these videos
coming for you comment what you want
more of what workouts you want to see
and if you want to see more guest models
cuz I know I do I'm a guest girl now new
baby and I'll see you guys next week
[Music]